how could I sauce up those hooks yeah so
on YouTube
um you know you're talking
about general questions that clients
have or people or viewers have now if
you're in a position where you have
specific knowledge on how you did this
or your client did this to make the hook
even more powerful you can say here's
how I did this or here's how I here's
how I made 1.7 million dollars with my
YouTube channel last year yes that's a
great hook right here's how my client
got here's how my client got two million
views on their third month or you know
whatever like if I were to do it for
reels I would say you know here's how I
grew an audience to a hundred thousand
in six months or in nine months or
whatever your whatever your achievement
was you could throw it in there powerful
it's super powerful because it's real
yeah now if you don't quite have those
results yet that's okay you can just be
an Enthusiast you don't have to flex but
so then you could say here's how you can
so here's how you can blow up your
YouTube channel in 12 months or less and
then you get into it you know so I think
I think you want to put what they really
want in that hook first that makes so
sense so if the problem is I want to
make money with a small audience rather
than being so on the nose I could say
here's how I made twenty two thousand
dollars last month in affiliate yeah
because you have to think like why do
they want a YouTube channel they want to
be YouTube famous they want to make
money they want a better lifestyle
here's to improve the quality of your
life yes here's how you can quit your
job with YouTube so quit your job is the
hook yes then if the problem is make
money on YouTube but you can hook it so
many different ways and you said that
earlier you said you kind of could have
sometimes come up with a hundred hooks
yeah so and the thing that's funny is
like as we're talking right now we get
into a mode where we could just write
100 hooks right now because it just
clicks and then you start to roll so
that's what happens to me anyways I
don't know if I'm unique but that's the
way I start writing them and then I come
up with a bunch and it's actually fun
because you're hacking attention it's
like a video game Instagram like how do
we stop the thumb two things number one
I've had too much coffee today number
two if you have not seen our free master
class yet you're gonna love it if you're
serious about growing your YouTube
channel just go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a a one hour
deep dive on-demand YouTube strategy
class it's sick and uh I'm gonna go
refill my coffee hope to see you on the
class